[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website cover
anything else 99designs was created to
make great designs accessible to
everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers for the 4-hour body
I want the contest route that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something
late night quick turnaround well people
in other time zones other countries can
also help you solve that problem since
then I've worked with 99 designs on a
separate path or a different option and
that is the one-to-one project service
so in a number of cases and I'll give
you one example when I wanted to create
the cover for my audio book The Tao of
Seneca this was a very important project
to me I decided to use their one-to-one
project service and with this service
you can invite a specific designer to
your project agree on a price and then
work together until you're satisfied and
they allow you to iterate and provide
feedback and all this stuff and I
haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators it blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter have done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free $99 upgrade
on your first design again that's 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high end financial advice that the
best private wealth managers delivered
to the ultra-wealthy but for any account
size and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealth front now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront
is powered by innovative technology
making it the most tax efficient
low-cost hassle-free way to invest they
don't have bloated sales teams or retail
locations so they can deliver all of
this sophisticated financial advice and
these services at a fraction of the cost
of a traditional financial advisor so
the very least go-to wealthfront come
forward / Tim and take their free risk
assessment survey it only takes a couple
of minutes and wealthfront will
recommend a personalized portfolio of
investments in other words they'll tell
you exactly where they would put your
money so even if you don't use their
service you have a huge leg up and you
have additional information for making
good decisions they use investment
theory to automate good financial
behavior and decisions that people
typically don't make but should so go to
wealthfront comm forward slash tim to
get your first 15k managed for free or
just to get more details check it out
wealthfront comm forward slash tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show I'm looking at into a
camera to record this as behind the
scenes and it's a little too weird so
I'm gonna look away and divert my eyes
nonetheless the Tim Ferriss show is
always about deconstructing world-class
performers teasing out the habits
routines favorite books etc that you can
apply to your own life and test
immediately whether those experts are
coming from the worlds of chess or
entertainment or sports business or
otherwise it is my job to dig into the
details this episode is a little bit
different but I'm very very excited
about it this is Debbie Millman round 2
now when Debbie first came on the
podcast I immediately knew when I hit
stop on my recorder that it was
something special what I didn't expect
necessarily was that her interview would
very quickly become one of the most
downloaded episodes of all time that's
out of more than 200 episodes just shot
way way up there I think it's passed 2
million downloads now Debbie at Debbie
Millman on the socials has been called
one of the most influential designers
working today she's the founder and host
of design matters the world's first and
longest-running podcast about design
where she's interviewed nearly 300
design luminaries including Massimo
Vignelli and Milton Glaser Milton Glaser
has a fascinating story in terms of his
10 year exercise that he did with Debbie
and she talks about that in the first
episode
Debbie herself has done it all her
artwork has been exhibited around the
world she's designed everything from
wrap wrapping paper rip
wrapping paper just since I flubbed that
one to beach towels and greeting cards
to playing cards notebooks to t-shirts
and Star Wars merchandise to Global
Burger King reprints she's a
best-selling author and has really tried
her hand at just about every aspect of
design and her story is incredible in
this round
- Debbie answers all the questions that
you guys were dying to ask her these are
your most popular so you submitted
questions and uploaded them topics
include how to turn down stability for
opportunity because she came from a very
conservative background was very
risk-averse how did she make the leap
how does she continue to try new things
how to outsmart the competition and any
job the future of graphic design her own
personal creative process
and the most valuable lessons she's
learned about life design so designing
an ideal life for herself which she came
to pretty late so there's still hope for
those of you out there thinking uh
something you have to do in your 20s or
while you're in college no not true and
she covers much much more so thank you
so much for submitting and uploading all
of your questions and I hope you enjoy
this episode as much as I did without
further ado as I always say here is
Debbie Millman round two hi this is
Debbie Millman and I am coming to you
from the Tim Ferriss Show where we are
conducting part two of my interview and
in this episode I am going to be
answering listeners questions these were
questions that were sent to Tim that he
forwarded to me so the first two
questions come from kocham ours in the
first question she asks for the exercise
where you write out what your life looks
like in ten years what if you see
multiple potential lives and don't know
which one will be better for you what do
you do gotcha my recommendation is to
write them all down I had and still have
multiple potential lives which all are
being lived at the same time I don't
believe that any one person only has one
specific calling I think you can have
lots of different things that you do at
lots of different times in your life the
remarkable thing about my life plan that
I did after Milton Glaser's class was
that not only did I write down my essay
but I also wrote down a list of the
things that I hoped in my best possible
life I could accomplish and they were
all from different parts of my life and
as the years have passed and it's now 12
years since I did that original exercise
year after year more and more of them
seem to be coming true almost magically
now it might be because I declared them
back then it might be because I've been
consciously or subconsciously working
toward those goals but I believe that if
it's something that you really want in
your heart and you put it out there you
have the potential no matter what walk
of life it is in
that you can accomplish them Koch
Amara's second question is as follows
you made the hard decision to turn down
the role of CEO and do your own thing
and it worked out well but by then you
were already established in your career
with major brands and bragging rights in
your portfolio what if you had done this
at age 30 or 32 or 27 what if you did
this before you even worked at a top
agency what advice would you have for
someone contemplating turning down the
stability of a comfortable known of a
guaranteed way to establish themselves
and build up a savings first for an
unknown to pursue their curiosities
right now rather than wait for the right
time so cocksure what I'm going to say
right off the bat is that there is no
right time I think that we humans delude
ourselves by thinking that there is a
possible right time that there's a
possible right time to quit a job or the
possible right time to have a child or
the possible right time to get married
and I think that because of the way our
brains are constructed we delude
ourselves with this our brains are
actually what are called the triune
brain it's a brain that is three in one
try and the three parts of our brain are
the neocortex the limbic brain or the
mammalian brain and the reptilian brain
or what Seth Godin calls the lizard
brain and the neocortex is the part of
the brain that controls much of our
modern thinking our ability to have
abstract language these are the parts of
the brain that marketers love so much
the limbic brain or the mammalian brain
is a part of the brain that all mammals
share mammals we're their offspring live
we don't hatch eggs we very much tend to
care for our offspring we have deep
feelings of connectivity and love for
others that is all coming from the
mammalian brain and then the reptilian
brain the oldest part of the brain which
sits right on top of the spinal cord
that is the part of the brain that
controls all of our involuntary activity
so our digestion our eye blinking our
heart
p-ting it also controls things like our
adrenaline so if you were to walk across
the street and nearly get hit by a car
you couldn't think at that moment
adrenaline kick in keep me safe
that is something that happens
involuntarily and the reason I'm telling
you all of this is because when we are
living with our reptilian brain which we
all do that part of the brain hates
uncertainty that is the oldest part of
the brain that kept us safe that keeps
wants to keep us secure that is the part
of the brain that is the deepest most
hardwired part of who we are and that
part of the brain doesn't like
uncertainty it doesn't like instability
it doesn't like being vulnerable and all
of those things that you're asking about
doing are all things that have an
uncertain answer that make us feel
insecure that makes us feel vulnerable
so you can never will in the same way
that you can't will that adrenalin you
can never will your reptilian brain to
be whoohoo change in security
instability vulnerability
bring it on we're going to have
tendencies to want to retreat from those
feelings and so one of the things that I
learned from doing design matters from
my guest Danny Shapiro was that
confidence and I think I mentioned this
in part one of my interview with Tim
confidence is overrated Danny Shapiro
has said that what is more important
than confidence is courage I believe
that confidence is developed over time
after repetitive success at any specific
endeavor the more you do it the more
successful you are the more confidence
you have that the next time you do it
you will be as or more successful what
is more important is courage because you
have to take that first step without any
guarantee of safety or security you have
to put yourself in a vulnerable position
and then just take that step so you
asked what I would have done at age 30
or 32 or 27 the fact of the matter is I
didn't have the courage or the
confidence to do any of the things that
I'm doing now at 30 or 32 or 27 I was
tremendously afraid that I was not smart
enough or pretty enough or talented
enough or connected enough or
enough to do any of the things that I
really wanted to do that probably
required none of those things I think it
just requires a belief that it's
possible which I didn't have so if you
want to do it now
my suggestion is do it now if you're
afraid to do it now try to live in a
moment of courage for one moment and
take that first step no amount of money
no amount of security is ever going to
give you the sense that this is the
right time because it's uncertain that
first step is uncertain do you want it
badly enough to be able to risk that or
not and that's the question that you
have to ask yourself Jimmy Scioto asked
two questions as well
he asks it was already hard getting paid
before so now with all these services
online competition based work and price
dropping etc it seems like the graphic
design market is losing a lot of value
au contraire Jimmy I disagree I think
the graphic design is more important
than ever what is happening though is
because it's more important than ever we
see a lot of people entering the market
that are willing to give it away for
less money but you do get what you pay
for and any service that's offering a
product that we do for less money is
going to provide less value initially I
was really really worried about all the
services that are selling logos for five
dollars and doing bidding and giving the
project to the lowest bidder and what I
found is that you really do get what you
pay for anybody that is going to those
services to get creative work is likely
not going to get the benefit of sound
strategic thinking which makes all the
difference in great graphic design I
believe that graphic design and branding
the culture or the condition of graphic
design and branding reflect the
condition of our culture and you're not
going to be able to get that kind of
work from a service that offers that
kind of work for five dollars so I don't
think you have to worry about that think
about how do you provide added value how
do you provide the benefit of what you
do best to your clients can you identify
what that benefit is if all you're
offering is good design that's kind of a
commodity what else can you offer can
you talk about
how your design is going to make a
difference people are not looking for a
difference in flavor or a difference in
form that are looking for how is this
going to make a difference in my life
can you prove what your work can do to
provide that Jimmy's other question is
where do I see a future for a graphic
designer
and my answer is the future is whatever
you make it whether you're a policeman a
fireman a doctor a neurosurgeon a
podcaster you create the future that you
want to create it is not specific to any
discipline
Ricardo McGill a house also has two
questions he asks the piece in the
industry is overwhelming and impossibly
hard to keep up with the feeling that
someone will do better than me why
bother
is a constant what are the right
questions to ask oneself actions to take
to prevent the act of creation from
being so paralyzing Ricardo I think you
would benefit from considering what is
the purpose of doing what you do is the
purpose of doing what you do for fame
for money for some sort of accolade
or is it for the sheer joy of doing what
it is that you're doing if you are
constantly comparing yourselves to
others and asking yourself why bother
then you have to ask yourself why am i
comparing what am I worried about why do
I need to compare I would also suggest
that you listen to the very beginning of
my episode of design matters with Sue
Matthews Hale sue Matthews Hale was
somebody that I was asking those
questions about as well on my podcast I
like to talk about the trajectory of a
life and how people overcome obstacles
and as I was researching her life I saw
this incredibly beautiful well-dressed
gorgeous woman who seemed to have it all
a great marriage a great child a great
career she had worked at pentagram she
was a partner at lip and cut the only
thing I couldn't find was where she had
grown up and what were her origins and I
did something that I rarely do I
actually wrote her and said hey sue I
can't find this information where were
you born where did you grow up when she
wrote me back the answers
me she wrote me back and said I was
abandoned on the street when I was 2
years old
in Korea I was left on the street I was
picked up and brought to an orphanage
where I was found by my parents you
never know what somebody's life is like
the arc of a life is a circuitous one at
any moment something wonderful or
something terrible could be happening
that we don't know concentrate on your
own life and doing what you want from
your own heart
try not to compete with others it's hard
enough doing what you want let alone
comparing what other people have or what
you perceive they have and I know that
that sounds kind of tough but I think
that thinking about what we want is hard
enough thinking about what somebody else
wants or doesn't want or does or doesn't
do you have no idea what their interior
life is like or what demons they're
battling your second question is what
questions do you ask yourself to
overcome the so dreaded impostor
syndrome when planning to do some kind
of work well that implies that I've
overcome the dreaded impostor syndrome
and I haven't I deal a little bit all
the time and the question for me is at
my age if I don't do it now when am I
going to do it if not now when
and so the question becomes do I want to
do this badly enough or do I want to
give in to the notion that I don't
deserve doing it and at this point in my
life I have to say if I want it badly
enough I have to do it I can't wait
anymore
Daniel Carbone asks how did you come to
the shift in your lead gene you
mentioned that your lead gene had once
been living in Manhattan but I'm curious
how and when that shift occurred well
Daniel it wasn't a shift so much as a
major realization I had been telling
myself for decades that I had
compromised on the intersection of 6th
Avenue and Bleecker Street in Manhattan
that summer of the police's
synchronicity and David Bowie's modern
loves and what I came to realize all
these years later we're talking 30 years
later before I had the realization was I
only compromised in that I didn't
compromise in the one most important
thing which was to live in Manhattan and
I did whatever it took I lived in this
awful deplorable tenement walk-up I
having to walk through somebody else's
bedroom to get to mine I lived having to
sleep on the floor one night because
they were busy doing what couples do in
the room that was preventing me from
getting to mine I didn't realize that
until years later I could have lived
anywhere I could have live with my
mother I could have lived back then
living in Brooklyn or Queens was really
really inexpensive I decided that I
needed to live in the most expensive
city in the world because I wanted to be
in the most exciting city in the world
and so I did whatever it took to be able
to do that at that moment in time living
as an artist would not have allowed me
to do that and so I made that compromise
in the face of making a decision about
what that lead gene was I just didn't
realize that for 30 years it took me a
long time to say hey wait a minute I've
been lying to myself all this time I did
do what I wanted to do I did that
because I wanted that more than anything
else and so one of the things that I
talked about is what is that
non-negotiable for you what is that one
thing that you want more than anything
that you're willing to sacrifice
everything else to get and that's the
decision that I made at that time Mike
Prendergast
asks you've been so influential on so
many properties from Star Wars to orange
juice I'd love to know more about your
approach what does your creative process
look like Mike my creative process is
really messy I don't really have a
process I don't know that there really
is such thing as a process a
cookie-cutter way of approaching
anything in terms of my approach I think
that I start out with a desire to make
something whether it be a package design
whether it be a podcast whether it be a
lesson plan whether it be a piece of art
and I have this vision for what that is
sometimes that vision happens really
fast and it comes when I've been
marinating and germinating and thinking
and thinking and thinking and sometimes
it comes really slow after doing exactly
those same things and feeling really
helpless that I'm never going to be able
to come up with an idea the one thing
that I can suggest is if you are stuck
take a walk
walking really helps me generate ideas
the more I walk the more ideas I have
um so in terms of approach think about
what you want think about what it is you
want to make think about the endgame
what is the vision of that look like and
then either start doodling start drawing
start making start sketching start
pulling your hair out whatever it takes
to get that process started and then
keep going until you feel like you have
something worthwhile that might take an
hour that might take a day that might
take a year that might take a lifetime
but I think if you enjoy the process of
making the fact that you don't have our
result makes it somewhat easier but I
say someone because I think the whole
idea of making anything in the first
place takes a great deal of courage good
luck with that that's been janae McKay
he asks do you do any other exercises
with your students like the 10-year goal
writing exercise and if not could you
speak to your time as a teacher and what
I've learned in helping others with life
design Aspen I spent a lot of time with
my students helping them understand how
they come across and this stems from the
notion of how do you want to be
perceived and one of the other exercises
that I ask my students to undertake is
to think about how they come across
think about what that first perception
is and I ask them to write two
paragraphs the first is what they
believe their first impression is how
they show up and what people perceive
about them the second is about what they
want their first impression to be this
culminates in their writing a statement
about what they project today and what
they project tomorrow
so for example I might write today I am
shy and recessive tomorrow I will be
more curious and engaging I call this
the intentional first impression we
should be able to determine how we come
across in a much more ownable and
decisive way don't leave it up to others
to determine who you are or how you show
up and if you think about how you do
this if you actually create a conscious
plan to be you on your best day when you
show up then you'll be able to show up
way it's not about manipulation it's
about intention I also asked my students
to determine the three word combination
that could only describe them and this
should be an accurate and deep
expression of who you are the three
words should be reflective of your full
self not just your best self so the word
should be cognizant of your strengths as
well as what you might perceive as your
weaknesses but I find that your
perceived weaknesses actually give us an
opportunity to peer into a part of
yourself ourselves that is really
meaningful if we dig deep enough for
example I had a student that identified
that one of her words of the three was
know-it-all and I asked her to
deconstruct why she was like that and
she identified that she came across as a
know-it-all because she was really
insecure about being smart and she
wanted to be perceived as smart and what
that meant was if she needed to be
perceived as smart and didn't just
accept the fact that she was smart that
she harbored a suspicion that she wasn't
smart she wasn't smart enough she wasn't
as smart as the other people around her
so by coming across as a know-it-all
she was compensating for this
deep-seated fear that she wasn't smart
enough and just knowing that just facing
that feeling that she didn't feel smart
enough allowed her to really understand
whether or not that was valid and she
wasn't coming then out of a place of
aggression or manipulation she was
understanding that her need to do that
was really trying to cover up a feeling
that may or may not be accurate and if
it wasn't accurate why did she need to
be doing that if it was accurate what
did she need to be doing that would
allow her to feel or be smarter and
improving that would help her stop
actually having to compensate for
something that may or may not be
accurate so think about what those three
words can be there should be some
tension in those three words ultimately
that unique combination if you really do
this successfully should be something
that only only could be used to describe
you but part of that is be
able to identify some of the things that
you're afraid of others knowing about so
spend some time with this exercise first
spend some time thinking about what your
intentional first impression is and then
spend some time thinking about what are
the three words that only could be used
to describe you taking to account that
some of what you perceive to be
weaknesses are areas that are available
to you to consider more honestly and
become stronger around
Kelcey helman asks Debbie how much of
your time is spent teaching college
courses how do you fit this into your
already busy career I've always been
fascinated by people who incorporate
teaching with their job and would love
to hear more Kelsey my first opportunity
teaching came as an undergraduate
teacher at the school of visual arts
where the chair of the graphic design
and advertising department asked me if
I'd be interested in teaching and one of
the things that I felt at that point in
my life was that I wanted to try to work
with students that were at the very spot
that I was at the corner of Bleecker
Street and 6th Avenue in 1983 how could
I work with students to prevent them
from starting to curtail the
possibilities of their life before they
were even possible how could I work with
students to help them to keep them from
editing what was possible in their lives
based on their own internal fears that
might not be accurate and so that became
my first class and I was teaching
students ostensibly how to get a job the
actual class is called differentiated I
had to get a job when you graduate but
really what I was trying to help teach
them was how to believe and what is
possible for your future and go after it
so it's not about just getting a job
it's about how do I fulfill my calling
how do I get the dream job how do I live
as if my life depends on my doing what
is in my heart and how do I make that
heart sing and so that has been the
basis of my undergraduate teaching now
for the last decade I started my
graduate program in 2009
when Steve Heller asked me if I'd be
interested in co-founding this program
with him which would be the first
program of its type in the world and I
jumped at the chance
I love teaching I feel like it's the
most important thing that I do what I
try to do with my students is instill in
them a sense of possibility a sense of
what is possible in their lives both in
terms of their calling as well as my
firm belief that branding is not just a
career about a return on an investment
of advertising and marketing and
positioning it is a profound
manifestation of the human experience
and that we are now using branding way
more than just being able to delineate
one product from another we're using
branding to help develop movements and
causes think about black lives matter
think about the pink [ __ ] hat all of
these things humans are using the very
tenants of branding to create social
movements and social change and that's
why I do what I do
Nicole Hanes asks how do you ensure a
healthy balance between work and play
Nicole this is where I might have to
reveal that I think that all of my work
is play at this point I have wanted what
I'm doing in my life for so long for so
long I've been longing for all of these
opportunities that now it doesn't feel
like work it feels like this tremendous
gift that I was given I didn't really
start doing the things that I love with
all of my heart my podcast my teaching
till I was well into my 40s and so now
that I have these opportunities to do
these things I'm just incredibly
grateful to have these opportunities and
I don't see them as laborious I just see
them as joy but I also caution my
students when they tell me that oh I
can't do that I'm too busy I tell them
hey busy is a decision we decide what we
want to do based on what we think are
the priorities in our lives and if we
don't get to them I suggest you look at
how important they are to you
how important are they is it more
important to watch Game of Thrones or
write an essay or paint a painting or
make a podcast and if those things are
more important you're never gonna get to
the painting or the essay or the podcast
and so we decide the things that we want
to do and if you feel like you're using
busy as an excuse to getting to do them
then they're just not that important to
you Nicole
also asks what do you think sets people
like you Tim and many other high profile
achievers apart from those who just goes
through life without ever really feeling
impassioned by their work well Nicole I
can't speak for Tim and I can't speak
for any of the other high profile
achievers here talking about what I can
tell you is that for me I have profound
insecurities and I use my work to create
meaning for my life I think that people
that goes through life without ever
really feeling impassioned by their work
might just have had really good
parenting and don't feel the need to
make a name for themselves by their work
because they feel just intrinsically
good about who they are
so if you aren't feeling impassioned by
your work and just feel impassioned by
life Bravo congratulations you have
something that very few of us actually
have Lee our shank asks to what extent
do you get creative blocks Malcolm
Gladwell mentioned that being in a
large-scale newsroom with tight
deadlines eliminated his writer's blocks
simply because there was no room for
such luxury I wonder if you ever
experienced similar effects how do you
stay so prolific Lee or I work under
tremendous deadlines as well and I find
that if you want something to get done
give it to a busy person to do if they
want to do it they'll get a ton and so
because of the deadlines because of the
constant pressure for a new podcast or a
new lesson plan which I can't really
control I feel that I have to operate
under this intense need to get it done I
do experience Bloch mostly from ideas so
for example if I have to write an essay
or if I have to create a piece of art
there
at times where I don't feel impassioned
where I don't feel the muse and that's
worrying because that does create delays
I find the best way to get over that
block is sleep
I feel more creative obstacles if I
haven't gotten enough sleep and sleep
regenerates your brain it regenerates
your cells and I find that if you're in
a regenerative state you're much more
likely to be creative
Emily e Godwin asks who are some of your
favorite visual artists well Emily
jean-michel basquiat is a perennial
favorite I also just met Deborah Kass
and I'm smitten with all of her work
Kathleen Dillon asks has Debbie found
common threads if any in her interviews
of creatives as to how they have
designed their lives and if so what are
they
Kathleen what I have recognized is that
almost everybody that I've ever
interviewed with the exception of two
people still face debilitating
self-loathing and also are tremendously
insecure about what they do I think that
people view high achievers simply as
high achievers and that they don't
experience tremendous self-doubt and
almost everybody that I've interviewed
whether they talked about it on the air
or not even in my research I found that
they questioned what they do how they do
it why they do it the only two people
that I've ever interviewed that seemed
to be really secure about what they were
doing in this world in their creative
life were Milton Glaser and Massimo
Vignelli and at the time the common
denominator that they shared is that
they were both in their 80s when they
told me this so I kind of feel like by
the time you get into your 80s it's like
hey [ __ ] it I am Who I am I do what I do
world be damned and I think that's
wonderful by the time you're 80 I think
you should earn that and so for all of
us out there that are feeling self-doubt
or are worrying about the value or the
purpose that we have in our lives
know that I think every single creative
person battles that too
Tony Fram asks in your view what are the
qualities of a good design student Tony
curiosity wanting to learn being excited
by learning always wanting to learn and
know new things those are the most
important qualities of being a good
design student so now I'm going to
answer some additional questions from
Tim Ferriss himself Tim sent me a whole
slew of questions and I'm going to
answer as many as I can
Tim's first question when you hear the
word successful who's the first person
who comes to mind and why I would have
to say Milton Glaser as I've just said
there's something about Milton where he
is just fully engaged with life and he's
been fully engaged with his creative
life for his entire life and he's made
so much impact he's created the most
profound logos magazines movements and
of course the I heart New York logo
which if there's any logo on this planet
I wish that I could have done based on
my love of New York and my love of
design it would be that logo so Milton
Glaser another question from Tim what is
something you believe that other people
think is insane well I am a conspiracy
theorist most of the clothes people in
my life think that I am insane for some
of the conspiracy theories I believe in
I'm not going to go into detail here
because I'm so worried that everybody in
the world listening to this will think I
am insane but if there is a conspiracy
theory out there chances are I believe
it what is my favorite documentary or
movie my favorite movie is Manhattan by
Woody Allen I love that movie I know
that movie by heart I also really really
love the movies last times at ridgemont
high and elf mostly because I don't stop
laughing
all through elf and I think that Jeff
Spicoli is one of the great characters
in all of cinematic history Tim asks
what are your morning rituals what did
the first 60 minutes of your day look
like
at this point in my life the first 60
minutes of my day are mostly about
trying to get my dogs out fast enough so
they don't pee on the bed or the floor
and I would say that only half of the
time I am successful my first 60 minutes
are a mad rush to get outside to make
sure that they can relieve themselves
without losing any of their dignity I
also try to have coffee at the same time
what obsessions do you explore on the
evenings or weekends I am obsessed with
sleep I love sleep I love having a
comfortable bed and beautiful blankets
and great pillows and so I am obsessed
with the notion of what can be
regenerating while I am in slumber what
is the best or most worthwhile
investment you've ever made it could be
an investment of time money energy or
other resource how do you decide to make
the investment I am the kind of person
that only likes to do things that I feel
comfortable doing it's very very hard
for me to do new things that I feel
awkward doing so when I tend to like to
do something I tend to do it as often as
possible and I think that persistence
and that resilience is something that
pays off in the long term by doing
something over and over again for as
long as possible but I think that my
best investment was probably buying my
co-op in 1993 in a neighborhood that was
at that time in New York City considered
a crack neighborhood which then became
the hiline neighborhood so I think that
quite by accident that became the best
investment that I've ever made do I have
a quote that you live your life by or
think of often I have a few but I think
my most heartfelt is everything
worthwhile takes a long time and that
has been a mantra for my life I also
really love a line from James Joyce's
Ulysses which is the longest way round
is the shortest way home which i think
is just a more poetic way of saying
everything worthwhile takes a long time
and maybe I just tell myself that
because most of the things in my life
have taken a long time and it's a way
for me to self-soothe
but I really do believe that the longer
that something takes the longer it lasts
and the less pressure you have to
sustain it for the rest of your life if
you could have one gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it what would
it say I love this question it's
something that I sort of have in my
office it's not a large billboard but
it's a chalkboard with one word on it
and it's high up on the window where I
hope everybody can see it when they walk
in and it says yes
try to say yes to almost everything or
say yes but or yes and some of the most
important things that I've been offered
in my life were opportunities that
didn't quite seem exactly right
but when I was able to say yes but how
about if we do it a little bit
differently or how would if we do it
slightly more like this those were
things that really did benefit from the
open - of both myself and the other
person that was offering the opportunity
look at opportunities as options in that
you can take those opportunities and
make them more about what you want or
what you can do or what you can create
and so think more from an opportunity of
how can i generate more from this as
opposed to how can I dream this away
this will be my last question what
advice would you give to your twenty
twenty-five or thirty year old self and
please place where you were at the time
and what you were doing I'm going to say
just anywheres between 20 and 30 because
I have often said that that decade was
ten years in experiments in rejection
and failure what I would tell myself is
stop worrying so much I would tell
myself that every dream that I've ever
had about who I could be would be
possible if I wanted it badly enough and
if I wanted it badly enough work as if
my whole life depended on it because it
did it would be it has
and so I would still even though it
would hurt like hell
go through want to go through every
single thing that I've gone through
because if I hadn't I wouldn't be right
here right now the arc of a life is
really circuitous and you never know
where you're going to end up but what I
can say is that despite all the pain and
the hardship and the abuse where I've
ended up right now is exactly where I
want to be and so even with those
moments of despair that I experienced
even what seemed like the worst moments
of my life those turned out to be the
most important the most impactful the
most necessary and therefore I wouldn't
change anything I hope you enjoyed part
two of this episode on the Tim Ferriss
show it has been a true honor to be on
Tim's show and I want to thank both Tim
Ferriss and all of his wonderful
generous listeners thank you hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront wealthfront
is the future of financial advice
they've become incredibly popular among
my friends in Silicon Valley and across
the country because they provide the
same high
and financial advice that the best
private wealth managers delivered to the
ultra-wealthy but for any account size
and at a fraction of the cost
for instance they monitor your portfolio
every day across more than a dozen asset
classes to look for opportunities to
rebalance or harvest tax losses now
would you do the same are you doing the
same probably not and the powers in the
software wealthfront now manages more
than four billion dollars in assets
which is up from around 2.5 billion when
they started advertising on this podcast
they're growing incredibly quickly
unlike old-fashioned Private Wealth
matters wealthfront is powered by
innovative technology making it the most
tax efficient low-cost hassle-free way
to invest they don't have looted sales
teams or retail locations so they can
deliver all of this sophisticated
financial advice and these services at a
fraction of the cost of a traditional
financial advisor so at the very least
go to wealthfront comm forward slash tim
and take their free risk assessment
survey it only takes a couple of minutes
and wealthfront will recommend a
personalized portfolio of investments in
other words they'll tell you exactly
where they would put your money so even
if you don't use their service you have
a huge leg up and you have additional
information for making good decisions
they use investment theory to automate
good financial behavior and decisions
that people typically don't make but
should so go to wealthfront compos on
tim to get your first 15k managed for
free or just to get more details check
it out wealthfront comm forward slash
tim this episode is brought to you by
99designs I've used 99designs for years
for all sorts of graphic design needs
whether you need a logo website we'll
cover anything else 99designs was
created to make great designs accessible
to everyone and to make the process of
getting designs much much easier so when
I first started out for instance testing
prototype covers and getting prototype
covers from the 4-hour body
I want the contest drop that is one
option this is a great solution if
you're looking for fast affordable
design work and the ability to choose
from dozens of options risk-free let's
say you need something late night quick
turnaround well people in other time
zones other countries can also help you
solve that problem
since then I've worked with 99designs on
a separate path or a different option
and that is the one-to-one project
service so in a number of cases and I'll
give you one example when I wanted to
create the cover for my audio book The
Tao of Seneca this was a very important
project to me I decided to use their
one-to-one project service and with this
service you can invite a specific design
of your project agree on a price and
then work together until you're
satisfied and they allow you to iterate
more I'd feedback and all this stuff and
I haven't shared it yet but we also got
some incredibly good really some of the
best illustrations I've ever seen from
using this one-to-one project service
with a handful of different designers
and illustrators they blew my mind 99
designs makes this all very easy and
efficient so you can check out the Tao
of Seneca design and other work that I
and your fellow listeners for that
matter I've done on 99 designs at 99
designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free and $99
upgrade on your first design again
that's 99 designs dot-com forward slash
Tim
you